[Musique]
angers caen aventure les appelle c'est
bonjour chers auditeurs tu veux écouter
les nouvelles aventures 10 rhys thomas
elliot
à mezel oublier elliott est abandonné et
ils se retrouvent aux états unis dans
les années 60 car l'irobot volti
modifier le temps quoi exactement vous
allez me demander
j'en sais rien je vous répondrais mais
cinq étoiles pour publier des couloirs
des bureaux c'est bien ça change un truc
trop dangereux salaires calmes mais j'ai
l'impression que le temps est en train
d'être toujours pas à croire qu'elle
vient de trahir son parti avec d'autres
au bol comme mon dieu vient de réaliser
un truc c'est la première fois qu'on
fait une mission que tous les deux et
alors ça te fait peur moi j'ai peur de
rien c'est juste que tu va en profiter
pour reconquérir et ça va me saouler je
ne comptais pas faire ça il reste mais
si évidemment on a déjà parlé thomas du
passé c'est pas parce qu'on a eu un
enfant dans le futur qu'on va finir
ensemble
ok allons voir si on peut parler à
quelqu'un et comprendre ce qu'ils aient
modifié salon avec tu dis allons un
genre tous les deux voilà tu oublies à
toi en utilisant la première personne du
pluriel
c'était très pervers narcissique bonjour
je peux vous aider
bonjour madame non pas madame
mademoiselle bonjour mademoiselle cathy
thomas enchanté bonjour thomas ravis de
faire ta connaissance je suis là
pardon je te présente quatre que si je
te présente iris mais j'étais là pendant
ces dix dernières secondes
cattier vous faites quoi ici enfin on
est où vous êtes dans le m haïti le
massage
institute of technology c'est ici qu'on
invente le futur vous inventer le futur
ça nous intéresse ça vous travaillez sur
quoi suivez moi je vais vous montrer ici
on n'a pas souvent le visiteur du futur
vous inventez du futur on s'arrête là
ici ma collègue de dénis travaille sur
une voiture amphibie décapotable patrie
[Musique]
alors ici boni travaille sur un
prototype et révolutionnaire
au culot mignon le petit chat oui mais
pourquoi vous le mettez dans un
micro-ondes
ce micro de serre réchauffent et les
êtres vivants en toute sécurité
[Musique]
quand il sera terminé
bien sûr c'est vraiment le futur que
vous inventez non parce que je suis un
peu scientifique et je veux pas être
impoli mais c'est un peu tous pourris
votre truc
iris non à la raison la raison on donne
tout ce qu'on a mais en ce moment on y
parle du non dit pas ça à cathy vous par
exemple vous travaillez sur quoi un
petit projet bof un truc qui marche sera
sûrement janet sûrement aurait dû
toujours ce sera forcément mieux que le
micro ondes pour animaux ça ça s'appelle
internet
coire un bon vous avez inventé
l'internet qui était vous êtes trop
forte vous en avez entendu parler c'est
gentil ça thomas attendait comment ça se
fait qu'on n'ait jamais entendu parler
de vous et puis il ya des filles ici oui
ici toutes nos inventions sont créés par
nous les secrétaires les publics oyonnax
qui marche
les ingénieurs mettaient un nom dessus à
la fin drame sur horrible une en
remettant des cheveux idiote non plus
l'un pour la création d'internet
j'ai réussi à négocier pour avoir trois
tickets resto et une place de parking au
moins deux hauts lieux du moins 3 et je
peux vous dire j'ai fait des jalousies
si c'est ça les robots veulent s'en
prendre à l'invention d'internet
cathy vous nous emmenez voir votre
prototype ah oui avec plaisir oui oui
c'est d'une importance capitale
j'ai tout émoustillé venez on va rentrer
dans l'internet le que la voiture j'ai
l'impression d'être dans le seigneur des
anneaux sauf que les nains sont des
jolies fils thomas
connaissez le seigneur des anneaux
j'adore les 9 de taux qui évidemment
tolkien c'est la base et aussi les
solives que j'ai oui vous savez tout le
monde se moque de moi ici quand je parle
du seigneur des anneaux
je pensais pas trouver quelqu'un qui tu
partages me facilement non plus c'est si
rare qu'on me comprenne recevoir être
thomas
moi aussi je connais le seigneur des
anneaux on ne sait pas si loin que ça ah
bon tu connais vraiment alors tu connais
tom bombadil totalement bah quoi c'est
lequel lui déjà c'est assez le nain
c'était un piège d'un bon ba dinh
n'apparaît que dans les livres pas dans
les films iris visiblement tu ne les a
jamais lui clairement à katie et moi non
mais attends tu allais me de quévy vous
parlez là nous voilà arrivés
préparez vous à entrer dans l'internet
j'ai trop excité je crois que j'ai fait
un pipi oui moi aussi comment ils
tellement pareil tellement dégueu ray
allez on ouvre la porte
ok vous
ça internet un gros frigo avec penta
attendez je vais vous faire une
démonstration
regardez j'appuie ici et attention ça va
nous faire un shack
[Musique]
aussi j'ai mal aux têtes aux chiens
regardez ce que ça imprime juste la
lettre w
[Musique]
et voilà d'accord je pensais qu'on
allait faire des jeux en vr entrer dans
une vidéo porno mais imprimé une lettre
s'est bien enchaîné très impressionnant
bon y'a rien qui vous paraît anormal
dans cette pièce
je suis sûr que les taureaux ont fait
quelque chose franchement non tu me
paraît normal vous entendez entendre
quoi le pipit ya 15000 bibine remonte à
l'époque ni les dix types je vous parle
du big bazar à wismes thomas c'est un
jour tu sais ça le bip bip
merci d'omar khadr sortez d'ici je vais
désamorcer cette
citons joie je sais ce que je fais
attendait dehors soit les prudes un
délice j'ai besoin d'un service fut le
jeu désamorce la brune et que je fasse
croire que c'est toi qu'on remercie
terre pâtes ou non mais je suis pas ton
pattes avant c'est quoi alors datchy ton
monta on s'affiche bon roman comment
faire aussi son moyeu depuis l'homme
était là et il a aidé a posé cette bombe
bon je vois te filent un rouge et un
bleu c'est sûrement l'un des deux mais
comment savoir
je vais voir s'il existe des tuto pour
désamorcer une bombe ok et tu vas voir
c'est tuto ou thomas et moi je vais
aller sur un oui ok mais tu es tellement
stupide stupide mais toi tu est pas non
plus alors que madame est censé être
super intelligente
vas-y tu es un truc pour moi j'ai
arraché un fils adam voilà c'est fait
pas oui ça va bien fait mais ça reste
complètement stupide
jamais content
[Musique]
tu as réussi c'est bon internet est
sauvé celui-ci courageux comme aragorn
du toit si belle et si intelligente
comme gandalf thomas tu sèmes parler et
toi tu me comprends tu sais toute
invention est une des plus belles choses
qui va m'arriver dans la via ya bien
bien
thomas handi'arts varrault bayal et ses
drôles de secondes terlouw à me casser
mes délires tout le temps comme ça iris
taille pack dire qu'on est que des amis
il va comporter en ami et comprend quand
je viens tout qu'un porto à ce que tu
peux être égoïste bien j'ai compris si
tu veux rester ici a pas de problème tu
as trouvé quelqu'un qui te correspond
après tout j'ai passé mon temps à dire
que t'étais inutile immature moche moche
oui dupouy stupid aussi pour ça va pas
tout énumérer non plus je vais pas me
plaindre maintenant tu veux rester
thomas s'il veut venir avec moi voir la
cafétéria
qu'est ce que tu voudras
[Musique]
je suis vivant en liesse le doc a bien
fait parié sur vous a plus que moi
maintenant avant tout le monde te cuite
ont duré faudrait peut-être se remettre
en question petite chérie
attends je suis avec toi tu veux pas te
marier avec ta nouvelle copine la non
mais attends c'est pas parce que je
croise une fille sympa que j'ai envie de
faire ma vie avec un hockey et puis à
par tolkien on partage pas tant de
choses que ça né en 1963 rebonds on y
voit ne tarde à donner votre prochaine
destination paris 1789 le 14 juillet je
me demande bien sûr qu'on va tomber à
cette taxe thomas cook n'ont rien répond
la négation
et voilà nos héros ont sauvé internet et
heureusement parce que sans internet
cette série audio n'aurait jamais existé
et ses prières aurait dû trouver un vrai
métier et je n'aurais jamais pu acheter
enfin je veux dire rencontré ma femme
sur internet avait à bientôt pour la
suite de l'épopée temporel et vive
internet
merci d'avoir écouté le 6ème épisode de
la deuxième saison de l'épopée temporel
et à la semaine prochaine